[Musique]
hier elle a pris plus de dieu il n'y a
plus rien alors benjamin castaldi qui a
fait son arrivée dans cette émission
cette saison c'est vrai que j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à convaincre parce que
amis ou des partis ils voulaient pas
faire les visites mais je cache un petit
peu les plaies c'est bon c'est bon c'est
pas grave ça va ça va guy davoult
benjamin j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à
convaincre
mais vraiment je dirai ce que je pense
de lui tout à l'heure et j'espère que
lui aussi il était avec nous ils nous le
dira vous allez nous dire si vous aimez
benjamin castaldi ou pas dans touche pas
à mon poste
vous aussi vous mettez votre note bien
sûr chez vous #f1 castaldi tôt car bien
sûr vous donnez votre pote à pajama pour
le moment regardez benjamin castaldi
depuis le début de l'année ses
prestations ses parts
[Musique]
salut tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
allez bages après c'était en 1992 le jeu
était diffusé sur l'assaut consigny sur
la jetée en mer
j'avais dit avant que n'arrive c'est pas
le point que ce soit avec marine le pen
ou l'article je ne comprends rien mais
discutent pas trop du cul
hier
m
les barreaux
machin
[Musique]
vision
très vite
sa chronique a été mauvaise
l'autre c'est le cas de benjamin
castaldi
on va démarrer par géraldine maillet que
pensez vous de lui
est ce que vous voulez mais est ce que
vous le détestez benjamin castaldi
benjamin castaldi vous êtes un
chroniqueur pour moi totalement rire ça
commence déjà vous connaissez son manoir
vous êtes un chroniqueur est patent pour
ne rien vous cacher vous m'impressionnez
vous avez trois qualités pour moi qui
sont primordiales et rare la première
c'est votre compétence vous êtes
compétent la télé coup d'envoi vaines
vous la connaissez mieux que personne
vous en connaissez tous les rouages et
vous êtes sans doute le plus légitime
autour de cette table moi je vous le
confirme le plus cher aussi alors
deuxième qualité votre humeur que vous
tombiez à cheval que vous divorce y est
que vous soyez au rhume et que vous
prenez un bad beat au poker vous avez
toujours le sourire c'est très agréable
pour nous tous autour de cette table
devrait sauf que derrière moi ça me
coûte cher troisième qualité
l'humilité mathieu tu sais ce que ça
veut dire
[Applaudissements]
je parle d'une bonne colle à la peau
quand je suis l'heureux chevaline
baumann vous avez été vous êtes une star
du paf
oui et pour autant vous acceptez d'être
à notre niveau autour de cette table à
tomber que à mon niveau et les niveaux
du rallye est très haut il voulait
accepter surtout que la rock star du paf
vous donne ou pas la parole et je trouve
que c'est exceptionnel c'est qu'ils leur
butin dans cette voie tu as bien vivre
les arts tunisienne doit alors gérant du
nord en babouches frère vous ai mis
uniquement 7 75 ans est là avec 7,75
vous explique vous qui nous regardent et
enrichissante à la date patrick et 10
mois mais dès cette semaine nous et
ensuite j'ai failli me mettre suite
ringer marais web on va vous avez
fallait peut être sa tête millions sinon
vous enlevez 0,25 pourquoi parce que
vous êtes un bluffeur flamboyant et en
fait vous jouez beaucoup mais vous jouez
pas ce que vous aimez jouer alors que
cyril lui il aime jouer pour gagner
uniquement
donc faites attention à vous oh la la la
la la
mais
et vous savez géraldine vous avez dit
beaucoup de vérité c'est vrai nom
benjamin c'est vrai nom mais ce n est qu
à faire et c'est vrai qu'ils jouent ce
qu'il aime jouer
oui tiens et c'est pour ça qu'ils n'ont
jour un peu poker au ping pong
non mais ça n'est pas l'égalé attention
alors 7,75 c'est la première note de
benjamin avant d'avoir les autres notes
est-ce que je peux mettre le générique
de touche pas à mon poste ah oui on va
me les belges fait le maître ok c'est
pas
[Applaudissements]
je
et oui mais sur pattes animateurs et
souple regarde ça en mai jusqu'au alors
les chéris on est sur le conseil de
classe de benjamin castaldi
merci d'être avec nous on a eu la note
de géraldine maillet qui nous a pris la
tête une 7,75 mais géraldine avait fait
encore une fois une analyse frappé au
coin du bon sens
j'essayais rap mais rossi est ce qu'un
pis aller de plus en plus belle sans
rigoler mais vous vous souvenez vous
êtes une étoile un qui ne part jamais au
ciel un c moi qui régale errer sur
l'image c'est pas nous voir l'attraper
alors qu'est ce qu'un bon pour
l'attraper ont lacéré au vote allez on
va alors on va faire vraiment on va
partir sur un autre délire complètement
pressure and in my heart on va partir
sur place piscine anna non mais c'est
bien méchant méchant mais c'est bien de
nommer louis mais des mots qui suivent
oui oui alors doc
je suis vraiment d'accord avec géraldine
c'est un qui connaît mieux la télé
autour de la table et en plus je trouve
ça extraordinaire qu'il accepte d'être à
côté de moi parce que ça a quand même
été un peu mon boss à l'époque donc
c'est un peu se rabaisser d'être à côté
de moi donc déjà braves personnes sera
baisse mais s'est quand même qualifié -
cast altig alors là mais tout le monde
mais on est tous égaux voilà un monsieur
fort équipe ça veut dire benjamin
castaldi les bons c'est pareil que
matthieu delormeau eux non on n'y voyait
que fout que les gens dont c'est quand
même un peu mais pas de talent mais
c'est pas vrai il ne vous rabaissez pas
vous êtes une ont filmé en tout cas
voilà il s'y connaît très bien il et son
fils quand il a un truc à dire il le dit
exemple on l'a vu dans le magnéto quand
ils ont quitté fes voilà quand il veut
faire un truc il moi j'ai mûri je
l'expliquais pourquoi j'ai mis quatre et
demi a quand même moi j'ai mis quatre
ennemis voilà petit gilbert des salins
j'ai mis quatre nuls parce que moi je
suis tout le temps à côté de lui dans
les émissions et quand il ya des
magnétos était tout le temps sur ton
téléphone doit déjà de 1 sam déconcentre
et 2,2 me regardait pas don que quand tu
canton quand c'est pas toi qui parle ou
qu'on parle pas de toi tu t'en fous
complètement
donc comment les magnétos tu es sur ton
portable c'est très agaçant et deuxième
chose pourquoi je n'ai pas mis la
moyenne c'est parce que dans l'es4 car
tu es très mission avec moi voilà la
nouvelle vieille mais ils sont tous cas
elle a dit ce qu'elle pense et méchaal
est c'est vrai que d'ailleurs je
voudrais interdire les portables à
partir de drogue lors être bien raison
vous dis ah bah oui je vous le dis a
fermé ses portes à partir de demain
alors isabelle morini-bosc portables de
leurs baux sur la table à partir des
sapins castaldi je vous parle non pardon
alors eh bien elle sur baby c'est la
mère supérieure sur ce qui vient d'être
dit capucine par benoît mais toujours de
bonne humeur non moi je les ai vus
souvent maugan et quand tu dis qu'il
n'aime pas ça lui est égal de pertes non
c'est pas vrai au grand concours il a
cassé un publi trois jours parce qu'il
permet je ne sais pas où quand tu aimes
turquie lapacas un public ce que vous
lui raconter des anecdotes maintenant
mais ça fait longtemps que j'avais perdu
moi c'était déjà loin
hommage à marley toujours défendu quand
il était à l'extérieur et que ici même
en attaque et donc je veux pas me mettre
à l'attaqué maintenant qui les lie tout
le monde aime donc moi je l'avais d'or
je laime dedans vous l'aimez ou levier
doit vous l'aimez maintenant de dans une
phrase que j'espère jamais dire sur
matthieu delormeau ses points forts sans
second degré son autodérision notamment
sur ses quatre mariages mais il n'est
jamais à la noce se termine toujours mal
fait ici j'espère que ça se terminera
bien mais il sait lui qui en parle le
mieux
j'adore et puis aussi son absence de
filtres sauf peut-être pour les
cigarettes mais alors il discutait d'une
façon c'est donc ça j'aime bien son
point fort mais c'est dramatique
particules pas pourquoi ne prend rien
que tu dis tu n'articule jamais alors
par points dont celui qui parle trop
près oui mais justement centre celui qui
parle trop fort est celui qui chante et
qui parlent trop bas et du coup moi j'ai
vraiment du mal à ajuster le tir toi à
mon âge de pourcentage et du mal
ajustées audika vous me mettez 2 après
avoir été tous les féroé
abalo elle n'a pas à l'abattoir jeudi un
tel rêve j'adore je lui mets neuf ans
mais ce qui est très énervé parce 9
thierry moreau
alors d'abord je dois dire un truc avant
de connaître benjamin j'avais l'image de
lui quelqu'un d'un peu distante d'un peu
arrogant de ma très sympathique et
j'avoue que depuis que je le connais
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un de sensible de
très très drôle avec un humour
incroyable et donc je suis très content
d'avoir fait sa connaissance vous le
voyez souvent voix soit quand même tous
les jours
as tu une vanne
[Applaudissements]
ses points forts c'est qu'il est bosseur
sur un thème de la mer et il m'était
quoi on a envie de faire mon conseil de
classe à toi vous allez me défoncer sans
déconner fossé de gattuso mathieu
non mais il a fait la même
merci c'est pas parce qu'il avait fait
la même peine qu'elle est bonne
thierry il est bosseur il connaît la
télé comme personne voilà je pense que
voilà ça c'est ses points forts ses
points faibles
et puis alors pour revenir à ce que
disait matthew dessus alors j'aimerais
beaucoup être à son niveau tu te moquer
de son niveau
j'aimerais bien être à son niveau de jeu
qu'on venait à faible buy je suis désolé
pour les points faibles c'est qu'il sait
beaucoup de choses et qu'en fait il
raconte pas tout il ya quelquefois il
n'est pas aussi méchant qui pourra
l'être sur certaines émissions parce que
je pense qu'il veut pas insulter
l'avenir ne pas insulter les patrons de
chaînes serrano qui dit pas toujours
tout à fait ce qu'ils pensent
donc je vais lui mettre la meilleure
note que j'ai me jusque là quelqu'un
sait si si
à travers sur les notes de matthieu
delormeau et de et de gilles verdez qui
sont toujours des surprises
j'essaie toujours objectifs en plus la
north bay son objectif est de alors je
suis désolé benjamin macé une bonne une
bonne surprise une bonne rencontre s'est
intégré immédiatement on a bien
accueilli ces intégrer immédiatement
il est très sympa à la ville comme à la
campagne
il est toujours de la ville à la
campagne cela qu'au boulevard avec l'uci
au milieu aquatique ckia est vraiment
vraiment bien qu'il n'est pas différent
à l'antenne que dans la vraie vie
voilà il connaît très bien
autre point fort et connais très bien et
télévision pour avoir allumé de très
nombreuses émissions à succès dont il
sait de quoi il parle il a gagné gardé
un très gros réseau dont il a souvent
des très bonnes infos en revanche un
gros point faible un problème de
comportement de quoi de comportement
adacore tient mal à l'aller toujours à
bachy ils parlent pas fort mais très
grossier il ya souvent des gros mots
voilà qui regrette après mais les a
quand même dit long c'est vrai que il a
une certaine légitimité et ils mentent
pas souvent toujours la parole pour
s'adresser à vous un peu irrespectueux
dont je jouais comme le suis je présente
enfin voilà ça fait partie des points
faibles donc pour toutes ces raisons je
mets non 6 assists
alors cette loque est vraiment elle ne
comptera pas dans la voyait bien sûr
assez dommage
non mais je vous dis mais qu'est ce que
parce qu'en plus il était sur nrj 12
mais stéphane et début moi je sais ils
se sont croisés stéphane qu'est ce que
vous pensez de benjamin castaldi vous
êtes le patron d'nrj 12 voilà alors moi
j'ai mis un dix premières c'est normal
non je trouve que tu as un grand
professionnel de la télé comme tous
autour de la table et qui est vraiment
ils aiment ça ils aiment l'art
techniciens comme tous autour de la
table
je sais que vous êtes très gentil mais à
capucine ne versez pas possible bien sûr
mais chirac géraldine c'est une
spécialiste de l'étude ont déjà vu leurs
basses mais la technicité des programmes
il aime les programmes il aime l'antenne
d'autre part il est généreux c'est
toujours été quelqu'un de là avec une
grande générosité les drôles après je
suis d'accord avec vous des fois il
parle trop vite et on n'arrêtait pas de
lui dire par le plus doucement à la sécu
mais sinon c'est un mec super sympa et
c'est ça qui compte
bah bravo il est alors là on va passer
aux deux plus sévère matthieu delormeau
et gilles verdez mathieu mon chéri pour
préparer ce conseil de classe je voulais
très très bien le faire dont j'ai
demandé à la prod un dvd de tes
meilleures interventions depuis six mois
on me l'a donnée et durer 25 secondes
alors mon cher six mois était marié avec
cyril comme sa seconde c'était pas la
sextape de thierry moreau
six mois que tu es marié avec cyril avec
l'émission donc voilà six mois de
mariage et avec pour toi c'est un record
donc que c'est très très bien j'ai très
heureux ton point fort moche ou vraiment
c'est l'humilité et ça je le reconnais
franchement venir comme ça quand on est
animateur dans une émission tu m'as
connu chroniqueur tu me vois aujourd'hui
et 30 pleine phase d'ascension en train
de décoller l'a380
ça pourrait être compliqué tu point que
sourire qu'est ce qu'il ya vous êtes
obligé de vous mettre dans tous les
conseils de classe ç'a eu non plus
tendance à parler de moi oui non pour
être sérieux deux minutes je connais
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'animateurs
courait pas accepter de se retrouver à
côté bas de jeunes de jeunes personnes
qu'ils ont vu dans des émissions comme
secret' qu'ils ont fait démarrer je
reconnais que franchement là dessus
sérieux deux minutes beaucoup d'humilité
tout ça avec le sourire et ça c'est vrai
point faible
mon show en revanche évidemment la
diction va pas s'éterniser dessus mais
là je reconnais que tout temps en temps
on comprend rien à ce que tu dis est
l'autre point faible
mon bébé c'est que et je peux l'entendre
mais comme tu attendant c'est un petit
peu à 1000 $ et tu as tendance à vouloir
faire un petit peu ce que je fais et à
revivre à revivre l'amour que j'ai avec
cyril essayer de toi aussi le vivre
c'est monsieur parent à vegas avec elle
mais kim par un week-end avec émeutes et
appelle tous les jours et sa gare sa
voiture à côté il nia nia nia nia tu
nous fais chier
[Applaudissements]
que moi c'est un à bagnols que je viens
à côté de lui c'est mon coeur j'ai dit
là j'espère que vous mais pour de vrai
vrai et là je suis sérieux vraiment tu
es une vraie vrai tu as un vrai vrai
vrai talent d'animateur tu es une vraie
qualité d'animateur et sa vallée faut la
voir ou pas c'était extrêmement
sympathique et c'est sincère et c'est ce
qui fait que depuis dix ans tu kartonn
donc pour ça et pour toutes les raisons
sassi du perso qui fait que tu es très
très généreux et que je garderai
toujours dans mon coeur c'est sincère je
tenais un 10 mois comme le nombre de thé
mariage
non mais c'est vrai que j'aime oui on
sait pour qui arrive on s'aime bien
[Applaudissements]
il a surtout peur que bat jamais
renégocier sur lui non non non non non
on fera plus de bisous loyal et 10 à
benjamin vous avez un immense point fort
depuis des mois vous êtes parti l'a
alors votre premier point fort vous en
avez deux en fait c'est que vous aimez
la vie vous vivez à fond vous êtes un
passionné et je vous ai découvert vous
êtes truculent c'est incroyable vous
êtes une boule d'énergie et je vous ai
même découvert sympathique c'était pas
gagné vu d'où on est parti et l'ignoble
conflit que nous avions eu de votre fait
que j'avais eu tant de mal à calmer
c'est vers un homme il a fait une phrase
la sûreté de l air aux dires et les
phrases que tu trouves dans les bleds et
là dans la loi il doit nous demandent à
la fois là-bas tout est le complément
d'objet nous autorisent ou non mais t'es
on est à l'étude accord
la ville présence incroyable vous êtes
convivial et vous avez un deuxième point
fort qui a été souligné ici c'est
qu'effectivement vous n'articule est pas
et on ne comprend rien à ce que vous
dites et c'est tant mieux pourquoi c'est
un point fort
parce que quand on comprend c'est
sûrement scandaleux c'est une
catastrophe bazin regardez moi vous êtes
à la solde des lobby des producteurs de
télévision
tout ce que vous dites est influencé par
vos amis qui tiennent les chaînes comme
l'histoire du 31 le fameux réveillon que
j'ai eu tant de mal à démêler
vous dites n'importe quoi avec aplomb et
comme vous avez été célèbre les gens
vous croit ça c'est un scandale c'est un
pur scandale
heureusement je suis là pour rétablir la
vérité alors benjamin vos points faibles
domine et c'est sans enthousiasme et les
yeux dans les yeux en vous adressant un
avertissement
vous êtes débutant donc je ne suis pas
trop sévère mais vous ne méritez pas
plus qu'un tout petit doux
[Applaudissements]
c'est surtout bon challenge dans un
instant c'est vraiment une très très
belle prise pour vous benjamin qui va
beaucoup vous émouvoir comme ça il
devrait savoir je vous donnais ma note
maintenant
benjamin c'est vrai que tous les deux on
est et on était un petit peu fâché mais
même quand on était fâché il y avait un
truc c'est vrai qu'on sait mais quand
même parce qu'on disait par les gens
interposés on avait envie de cela on a
envie de se revoir c'est vrai moi jamais
en tout cas sur touche pas à mon poste
moi je suis vraiment je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est devenu
indispensable à l'émission benjamin
quand il n'est pas là je vous le dis
aussi ben ça m'embête tous les soirs
quand j'arrive je dis est ce que
benjamin il a est généralement il est
déjà dans ma loge en train de manger des
cacahuètes
non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai benjamin
vraiment je trouve qui au contraire de
ce que vous dites je trouve qu'il prend
beaucoup de risques
mine de rien je pense qu'ils allaient
moins en prendre cette année parce que
ils donnent beaucoup sur la vie sur les
émissions sur les animateurs alors que
derrière il sait très bien qu'ils vont
tous la plaie qui vont lui dire oui je
vais te blacklisté tu vas plus faire si
tu vas plus faire ça et ils misent
vraiment sur l'avenir avec nous c'est le
sentiment que j'ai en tout cas avec
benjamin avec nous et essai 8 et
vraiment je trouve que c'est une
excellente recrue et aujourd'hui je peux
le dire
non seulement c'est quelqu'un avec qui
j'aime travailler mais c'est vraiment un
ami pour moi moi j'adore vraiment il le
sait
sur six qui peut vraiment compter sur
moi c'est un ami
et vraiment il a qui se passe pas un
jour sans je n'ai pas benjamin théo ne
vois là même le week-end ou pas des
week-ends en somme voilà je l'adorent et
ne trouve vraiment vu parce que benjamin
je vous dis la vérité
benjamin il a été un niveau qu aucun
d'entre nous n'a connu voilà il a été
une star comme vraiment voilà est plus
que tous ici et aujourd'hui il est avec
nous il est dans la même aventure et il
se bat pour l'émission il regarde les
scores tous les matins il à fond avec
nous et vraiment je laime très fort
merci maman a fait une rentrée
exceptionnelle et vraiment on est très
heureux talent avec pour seul à jumet
1,9 à bercy le petit point faible
le benjamin de fribourg fait c'est ce
que je lui dis à chaque fois et c'est
vrai que c'est le contraire de moi je
lui dis tu parle un peu douce beaucoup à
toi là il a tendance à nous faire une
ambiance parfois on dirait qu'il
commente un match de tennis il faut oui
c'est vrai moi ça me plaît
1 c'est ça mais bon ça c'est rien c'est
juste on va juste un petit peu remonté
le sont et puis en plus y'a tata
isabelle qui est pas bien sinon elle
entend pas d'accord fellow mois pour
riza mon chéri attends attends il ya ma
maman qui m'envoie un sms au nombre elle
aussi voilà et à ma mère à te mets un
radar mais j'ai une surprise pour toi
vraiment là c'est en vrai moi je lui
mets 10 même si ça ne compte pas kim a
écrit ça c'est aurore c'est affamés qui
haïssez net et qui peut être vécu
nous regardons d'abord devoir
cela demande des truites aussi la note
globale bassam est ce que tu as quelque
chose à dire d'abord merci beaucoup pour
tous ces compliments et ses vérités
c'est vrai que j'ai quelques défauts pas
tant que ça mais on est quelques-uns
c'est vrai que je voulais pas venir
voilà c'est pas un secret je voulais pas
venir dans l'équipe je pensais qu'on
pouvait pas être dedans et dehors qui
était compliqué de critiquer le travail
des autres et finalement c'est super
jouissif de dire du mal des autres
non je plaisante
et j'ai découvert des gens tous ici je
pouvais pas saquer verdès et je peux
toujours pas le sac et il ya une vraie
c'est en fait c'est une vraie famille on
s'entend tous très bien on se dit des
saloperies par derrière mais globalement
c'est très agréable de bosser ici une
bosse contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser même si on dit beaucoup de
bêtises apparat par jean mi mai mais on
serait qu'on travaille pas mal sur
l'émission moi je passe du temps pour
préparer ce que ce que je vais dire
m'étais je dit pas et je suis très
heureux ici et je regrette d'avoir dit
ce que j'ai pu lire même si parfois ça a
été un peu loin mais c'est vrai que
c'était compliqué pour moi donc je suis
très heureux et je remercie infiniment
syrie
[Applaudissements]
réputé 6,1 encourageront bassam je crois
qu'il prend la deuxième place du
classement
benjamin des chroniqueurs alors on va
voir troisième place alors atteint 6,4
moyenne soit les encouragements donc le
les téléspectateurs dont pianote aussi
sert à les libérer du droit du sol air
basa 24 à 12 merci mon avis tu passeras
ce faire sur ma vie traiter 30
[Applaudissements]